.
D
HIM  T TIME WAS FOERA AR JOHN IS
PPE,BUT TWICE DU HIS CAREER.
HEN SENIOR
SPTS ANALYSTABOUT IT
AW YOU
EMTH LUIS DIAZ
AFHI
URHER WAS KIDNAPPED
TWICE.
TIME?U TALK US THROUGH WHAT
YEAH.
ISHED WORK AND WAS GOING
ME, WITHAN GWENTN PULLED OVER A.
HE WAS TAKEN.
WAS ABOUT
10 D AND
USON
HEY WAWITH ME.
HE
AMOUNT OF MONEY, YOU K THAT
NEEDIF YOULP, IF YOUHAVE TO MAKY
NEED ME TO GET TO SET  PEOPLOVE.
SO, HAHEMONEY, AND TRE. THE FIR.
ATBRKI.
WEN LIKE?
YEAHOUGH.
R DA, KN Y
STWA,
ANO THERE ANDCK UIKHE
BR.N EVERYWHERE.
HAD SWOLLEN, THINGS LI THAT.
HE WASREAKINGAN'T MOVE
ILY.
EDHE 2ND TIME? 2NDIM I
MAGI AKING TO MBEFORE G LIKE,OM
CAN'T PLAY. ARE NOT IN THE RIGHE
THE LEADER.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I DID.
'TGAME.
FI
UP.THROW
I ALL
LLAPSE OG.
D YOU REACHED OUT TO
LUIS.
WERE YOU A GIVE CTH>> NO, I DIY
OWT HE'SNGHOI FEEL
THROUGH.
OW A DIFFI
NEED,YOBOAVE TONTEN